welcome all to this third talk in the
seminar series on climate extremes yci
from a seminar series on climate
extremes this semester today's speaker
is christopher Williams from clark
university christopher got his PhD from
duke university in 2004 then went on and
was a research scientist at CSU Corrado
State University for about three years I
believe and then went to Goddard
university of maryland for a couple of
years and was a research scientist there
and in 2008 went to clark university and
as an assistant professor there since
since then in planning the seminar
series we became aware of Christopher
and his colleagues work through a new
york times article that i forwarded this
morning and it had a catchy title of
prediction for the next century drought
so we're interested to see the research
behind that article and Christopher
Morris course thank you very much can
everybody hear me in the back is it ok
great so I just want to thank whoever it
was in this room who managed to pull off
this series it's a great pleasure to get
to be here to speak with you today and
it's it's great that we could schedule
this between extreme events I think we
have another nor'easter of sorts coming
through on Wednesday or so I was just
being told by Trudy so and also thanks
Trudy for hosting me so before I get too
far along I want to confess to things I
first of all I changed the title just a
bit and I changed it because this is a
presentation the kernel of this
presentation is something that I've
delivered in scientific meetings in a
15-minute format but to try and blow it
up to full seminar I decided to attempt
to provide a broader context from what
you would normally get to present as
background for the science that we have
contributed
with this work so I've exchanged the
title to be a little bit broader drought
in the American West assessing
biophysical and water resource impacts
the other thing I'd like to do is
confess that a good fraction of this
work was conducted when Christopher
Schwalm now at Northern Arizona
University was a postdoc with me at
Clark University he's there now as a
research scientist and he's actually the
one who was first invited but because he
wasn't able to make it I'm very happy to
be able to be here in his place to
present his work in our groups work
kevin schafer also deserves some credit
he's at the National snow and ice data
center in Colorado and there's a broader
cast of characters I can't name everyone
today this work has been partly funded
by the National Science Foundation
atmospheric sciences carbon and water in
the earth system a grant awarded to the
three of us as well as some NASA funding
that we've drawn upon from terrestrial
ecosystems so I'd like to give them some
credit so this is a story in five parts
I'll probably make it through three
perhaps for the first part is about
water in the American West and it will
involve a quick lesson a short lesson in
climate ology I'm sure very pedestrian
for many of those in the room right now
but I've been told that this can be at
times a broad audience so I'm going to
try and provide a backdrop which
characterizes the the drought in the
West that we were detecting within or
embedded within a broad dry state and
then what are some of the ways in which
the west of the u.s. uses water that
might be different from other parts of
the country will then move towards a
kind of a vignette of an extreme event
that happened recently and then how this
was a series of years of unfolding
drought that made it remarkable the next
thing is about how it was remarkable in
the long-term context looking back to a
thousand-year tree-ring chronology to
place this extreme drought event that
happened at the turn of this most recent
century in a longer historical context
and then we'll look at the future and
we'll do that by focusing on climate
model forecasts under high emission
scenarios that is greenhouse gas
forcings because of the
the fossil fuel driven way of life that
we lead today and what that might bring
to the future in terms of water
availability in the western United
States and then also there's a global
context to that story will we be
spending the majority of our time on the
second piece which is the the science
that we've contributed but by way of
background I just want to introduce from
a non climatologist why the West is dry
in essence and what that means so the
western United States is dry by nature
it's dry by nature in such a way that it
actually generates a textbook example of
the dry humid boundary this is a graphic
simplifying the kirpan Geiger
classification of climate and it draws
it traces a very clear division down the
center of the contaminants us separating
a region on the left of the West that's
quite dry from a region on the east
which is relatively humid how do we
define dry how is this boundary defined
well it's really defined by a simple
supply and demand the demand is the
atmosphere drying power of the air and
that is humidity and wind speed to some
degree but there's another component
which is the radiant energy input that
is sunlight and a good proxy for that
turns out to be mean annual temperature
for these climatological timescales but
even better would be potential
evapotranspiration so that's on the
demand side but what makes a place dry
is not just demand for moisture by the
atmosphere of course also supply is
important and this is where
precipitation comes in this is not
rocket science the basic idea that mean
annual precipitation is a good
determinant of just how dry a place
tends to be and also important is it
seasonal delivery does it fall in a cold
season or a warm season so the
combination of these factors is what's
used to trace this boundary that
separates the west and the east with a
generally dry state in the West but why
is that the case this is a slide that
comes from lutgens and Tarbuck and this
is a nice example I think of how my
teaching of weather and climate gets to
there's a broader benefit for my
research this this graphic from the
textbook the atmosphere by lutgens and
Tarbuck demonstrates how there's moist
the the equatorial heating generates a
lot of moist air that rises generating
cloud formation and actually driving at
equatorial to poleward circulation
system as everybody here knows that
circulation system isn't one large cell
but in fact it because of radiative
cooling in the upper atmosphere as well
as the fact that rainfall essentially is
concentrated in equatorial zone water
rains out we end up getting a drier
upper atmosphere that becomes highly
stable and there's descending air the
Coriolis effect deflects winds
generating what we call the subtropical
high pressure zone this subtropical high
pressure zone brings a prevailing state
at the surface of dry atmosphere
condition the dry state and it just so
happens that western North America is
located at a latitude that's consistent
with this zonal condition of a
subtropical high there's also a
situation in which oceans tend to have
strong high pressure systems and those
high pressure systems are stronger on
their eastern sides than on their
western sides so the outflow from a
anticyclone system here generates brings
maritime tropical air to the eastern
side of the continent keeping it
relatively moist on this side where it's
we don't have that same prevailing
condition we have a strong high pressure
system in the ocean and a prevailing dry
situation in the western side of the
continent so that's just simple classic
climate ology the idea here is that the
American West is dry by nature this this
simple division is actually a bit more
complicated even than what this would
suggest and this is a map of the kirpan
Geiger classification B is the dry
climate type and you can notice a
prevalence of the dry climate type which
corresponds to desert and step
conditions but we also get some
interesting seasonally wet cold season
Mediterranean type tropical subtropical
ecosystems in parts of California and
then also a marine West Coast climate
type so there are some wet regions but
the prevailing condition of the West is
one that's dry you might think that that
east-west difference in climate would
that up a different pattern in water use
between the East and the West so as I
was preparing the seminar I started to
dive into the wonderful data available
online about how water is used and
aggregating this up to western and
eastern states for right now this is
just to mark what I mean by the West
everything else to the right of that in
the contaminants us i'm calling the east
and it there are a few interesting
points that emerged first of all there's
a story about the thirsty western third
i would call it this is that about
thirty eight percent of the conterminous
us water supply is consumed but it only
has about 28 percentage of the total
population so that's a relatively
thirsty average consumption of water so
right now that's just a comparison of
this number and that number relative to
the totals we also see that there's
about five times as much irrigation what
are used and withdrawn for irrigation in
the west compared to the east and
furthermore we get a very stark
difference in thermal water use for
thermoelectric power in this dry context
there is is hardly any water withdrawn
for the generation of electricity
thermoelectric power in the west 18
times less water use for thermoelectric
power generation so that might lead you
to think that at least the energy sector
would be buffered from shortages and a
dry future in the West but what do you
think it is that gives the West all of
its energy turns out that hydropower is
a very important source that makes up a
very big part of the difference so this
is just for the electricity generation
alone but about forty percent of the
West's electricity is generated from
hydropower very large dams sometimes
small and this is a very important
substitute for other energy sources
things that would require water use for
thermal electric energy production in
the northwest it's as high as seventy
percent so this is a very large fraction
of the total water use and of the
generation for the generation of
electricity so water is still very
important for
energy generation in the West and
they're actually a couple of significant
problems with this fact first these
large reservoirs lose vast quantities of
water to the atmosphere because of the
extremely dry state in which they're
embedded you can imagine these the the
atmospheric demand in this arid
landscape is very high you give it a
free water surface to draw moisture and
you're going to end up having very large
evaporation rates so that's one problem
in a large fraction of water that flows
in these rivers is lost to evaporation
the other problem when it comes to
electricity production that I've
recently learned about is that shortages
in supply reduce precipitation on
catchments in the arid West that are
used then for electricity end up
becoming amplified in their impacts on
electricity and that's because every
drop is used multiple times through a
chain of turning turbines and so this
actually underscores a strong dependence
and and connection between water
availability and electricity you might
not see that in any given year if you've
got a vast reservoir relative to the
amount that's delivered downstream they
may be able to smooth out some of the
year-to-year variations but a long-term
change in water availability will
clearly translate to a reduce potential
for electricity production through
hydropower in this region so that's part
of the backdrop and that led me to think
a little bit more about electricity this
being the climate and energy institute I
thought why not throw up a few energy
oriented statistics and this was great
fun to do into the wee hours of the
night so this is now west and east
sources of electricity and some very
stark patterns emerge the West uses much
less coal it uses much less nuclear for
generating electricity and it uses of
course a lot more hydroelectric as I've
just motivated or explained it also uses
less energy total on a per unit area
basis right this is british thermal
units adjusted based on the efficiency
of production per kilometer square but
when you consider the fraction of u.s.
population this sixteen percent of total
and 22
% of total looks more similar so it uses
less energy overall but there are fewer
people in the West than the east so
that's part of the story but again
hydropower is a very key source of
electricity suggesting that droughts
would translate or could translate to
shortages not just in say carbon and and
drinking water supply but also
electricity production now that's not my
research this is a sort of backdrop
there's one other backdrop that I want
to mention which is agriculture 50
billion dollars a year are generated
annually as net farm income and a good
fraction of this a meaningful fraction
let's say is contributed by the Central
Valley in California and some parts of
the West now obviously the Corn Belt
sand and wheat regions and livestock
production in parts of the East generate
the lion's share but let's not
understand under appreciate the
importance of in particular Californian
production so again there's this
important connection that may be
measured in terms of billions of dollars
that droughts would bring to this region
this part of the West so all of that is
kind of table dressing for what it is
that I want to present to you today
which is an account and an unpacking and
the folding of a particular drought
extreme this is an event that transpired
over the course of about five years at
the turn of the century and had I think
I'll convince you of far-reaching carbon
water and potentially energy
consequences and we want them to think
about that and in in this long-term
history and this future context so
that's where we're headed at the turn of
the century that is around the year 2000
the western United States experienced
the beginning of what would be a
five-year prolonged moderate drought I
say moderate because over this large
domain traced in the red box here not
every place experienced drought in every
year and not every place experienced
severe drought but most places
experienced severe drought and the
prevailing condition was dry this showed
up in a variety of indicators I'm
showing here
cipa tation from the crew data set and
we can see three years prior in blue a
couple of years post in blue and then
the five-year period of drought you can
see in general below average or average
conditions in terms of precipitation we
see below average soil moisture and
these networks are not continuous and so
some of the disagreement could be due to
the vagaries and the details of those
networks when it comes to the Palmer
drought severity index we see that
especially in two thousand two three and
four there was a prevailing condition of
a dry state and that's integrated over
the entire western US domain I don't
know if you can see it but if you can
these faint gray lines indicate a one
standard deviation departure from normal
that shows us that when it comes to
Palmer drought severity index while
there was a prevailing condition over
the region this was not in any one year
severe over the entire region and we're
next going to look at the spatial
evolution of this drought each year at a
time all the same the fact that these
happened one year after the other had
compounding effect there's a question
the Palmer drought severity index is a
combination of what I mentioned before
supply and demand some drought indices
like the SPI the standardized
precipitation index is all about water
shortages from precipitation and that's
a pretty good metric but there's another
side to the drought condition and that's
about water shorey atmospheric demand
you can imagine a dry state from an
atmosphere that was especially good in
one year at demanding moisture and so
that demand side is taken also into
account with the PDS I some other
drought indicators don't also consider
the drought the demand side of that
equation there's more to it and it's an
imperfect index we can talk about those
details but this is one of the industry
standards the gold standards that's used
so this is a map of the Palmer drought
severity index in August 29 on August 29
of two thousand and you can see a lot of
yellows and oranges of varying intensity
and this is the beginning of
what would become a five-year prolonged
drought over the region it wasn't severe
over most of the domain only a few
places experience severe to extreme
drought but that's still meaningful but
what happened over the next year was a
continuation of drought over the region
of prevailing condition now this pattern
shifted to the northwest and it
intensified over some regions you can
see a clear belt of intense drought and
extreme drought but other parts of the
domain cease to have in it as intense a
drought in 2002 about the whole map is
experiencing some degree of water
shortage and a large portion this domain
experienced extreme to exceptional
drought from a from a hundred year kind
of perspective in 2003 that continued so
we have yet another year of severe or
extreme drought over much of the domain
and into 2004 we saw yet again in some
of the same areas a significant drought
and again a lot of reddish and orange
colors throughout that domain so one of
the things that I want to impress upon
you is how with this picture how most of
the region experienced at least one red
year okay one year with water shortage
and much of the domain experienced
severe drought at some point in
particular the extent of drought in 2002
in the West only this domain only was it
exceeded the extent of drought during
the Dust Bowl for this region now i'm
not talking about what's happened on the
interior where the Dust Bowl was
concentrated but that's a useful
reference for many people ask me well
how was this how extreme was this with
reference in comparison to the Dust Bowl
for the western region it was more
severe and more extensive we what did
this translate to in terms of water
fluxes and carbon balance those are the
things that we studied the most and work
on the most in my lab and I'm going to
show that in three different ways here
really first then I want to focus on the
second panel that is normalized
difference vegetation index again the
blue dots are three years prior or three
years after and the five red or the
the turn of the century drought period
and clearly the vegetation greenness as
seen from satellites was on average
lower and in some cases much lower than
the average outside of this drought
period there's a clear contrast there we
see the same thing when it comes to
evapotranspiration this is
evapotranspiration coming from modis
driven product this is a modus derived
evapotranspiration it's very hard of
course to get evapotranspiration and
continuous format but satellites provide
some indication and with models coupled
to the satellite record were able to
derive essentially what the
evapotranspiration condition was like we
see sizable departures again I apologize
if the gray lines are hard to see but in
some years it was well outside one
standard deviation over a 20-year type
period we used Mira to look at
evaporative fraction and this is the
actual evapotranspiration divided by the
potential evapotranspiration and we see
reductions in evaporative fraction that
is its commensurate and similar to the
reductions in evapotranspiration very
similar kinds of metrics different
sources of information and what I think
you can see is that there's a
corroboration by using many different
lines of evidence about the magnitude of
this drought and how those five years
are offset from the prior three or the
post three so that's what we attempted
to do is to provide a comprehensive
overarching view of the environmental
conditions and the water resource and
and carbon impacts of this drought we
see
because if you do that refraction there
that conversion occurs both dip down we
don't know that that's because it's less
water leave a dream or some changes you
have to stir that's right but that's
part of what the evaporative fraction
allows us to assess because again it's a
ET / PT so an anomaly in a ET / PT
removes the potential influence of the
potential evaporation and it focuses
more on the water supply side so in
combination these to provide
corroborating evidence that it was
really water supply not demand that
caused some of this shock here's looking
at the same sort of thing in a spatial
context and now on the Left I'm showing
again this vegetation greenness or NDVI
in the middle we have a soil moisture
product and we have the palma drought
severity index on the right what's shown
here is drought minus non drought
conditions so that is the 5-year average
for the drought minus the prior three
plus post three average and you can see
there's a lot of red that's the main
story and that overall there's a
coherent water shortage that showed up
in reduced greenness of vegetation
reduce soil moisture on average and a
negative anomaly in the polymer drought
severity index so we see that there's a
coherence spatially but also across data
sets now we're going to turn to a
different data source which is another
way of looking at the same kind of
problem this the impact of the drought
is now going to be assessed using
hydrologic gauging stations and these
are data from the USGS available at
their water watch site have some
animation here okay so for these major
basins we have six major river basins
the Pacific Northwest California Great
Basin Lower Colorado upper Colorado and
the Rio Grande so for these six basins
we want to know what the river flow
anomalies were like did they experience
reduced river flows I'll show in just a
moment that there were large reductions
so now we're showing again 1997 to two
thousand seven or eight two thousand
seven years prior years post and our
drought period there's clearly a
reduction in total runoff a change in
annual runoff across all of the six
major river basins that's clear that's
very well offset from the three years
prior and the three years post the upper
Colorado in the Lower Colorado were some
of the most impacted they experience the
most severe and continuous droughts and
so you see while they may not have had
the largest total reductions the upper
Colorado for example had sustained
reduction in some cases runoff was
reduced by about fifty percent from
normal this is a pretty sizable
reduction from the average condition
where in this case the average is
calculated as the mean across all of
these years so again a clear drought
minus non drought contrast and this is
showing the same kind of picture but now
spatially so we've got two thousand in
the upper left two thousand one in the
bottom left 02 in the middle and so
forth what's shown here is red is the
percentile relative to a hundred and ten
year historical record of river flows
and if it's a less than 10 that means
it's it's in the it's less than 10th
percentile we see a large fraction of
the country experiencing much reduced
river flows especially in 2002 and these
are of course consistent with the kinds
of spatial patterns that we saw a year
in year out as the drought the five-year
drought evolved we saw the shift to the
northwest in 2001 we saw a strong
interior signal in o2 and o3 and it
persisted even in 04 so three years of
low runoff especially in the upper
Colorado and Lower Colorado River Basins
so we see it spatially and now we can
look at it in a tabular format with some
basic statistics we're just going to
look at ranks and in this case I'm
reporting the five-year average flow for
each of the basins and it's the in fact
it's the number of year
is with a five-year average flow that
was lower than the average during the
turn of the century drought and you can
see that in a hundred and ten year
record the upper Colorado in the Lower
Colorado never had a year with lower
five-year average runoff so this was a
record-breaking event for those in
particular those two basins we see it
was also record-breaking for most of the
basins the Rio Grande is showing there
was only one five-year average that was
lower than this we see that even in the
California it was ranked as the tenth
lowest so it's low overall especially in
some basins and we could also start to
look at whether or not historical
droughts of note were were were captured
in the same records I won't go into
detail except to say the 80s droughts
were in some basins the Dust Bowl was
clearly evident in the Great Basin and
actually California as well the 50s and
60s droughts showed up in those same
basins and so it's not that these were
the the turn of the century drought was
the only major one but notice in the
places where the other droughts were
significant it modified the statistics
the rank wasn't as low but these were
real records for the Colorado's basins
especially yes
that's a great question I'm not sure I'm
the best one to answer that that the
people who procure the data and make
them available say that back to the
1930s is where we have the most
confidence so I'm going to go on faith
and trust their intuition for that
anything prior is more questionable it
turns out that in the West and across
much of the country prior to the 1930s
was a relatively wet period and so I
don't think we would have missed a lot
of dry and statistics from that first 30
years of record here sorry I can't give
you a more satisfying answer but state
of my knowledge I'm so another way to
look at this is for which what was the
rank of the single lowest run off of the
five years of drought and we see in the
upper Colorado and Lower Colorado the
year 2000 was the lowest ever this is
now just single you're not five-year
average so forget the consecutive nature
2002 was also in the Lower Colorado the
third lowest runoff ever third lowest in
the Pacific Northwest in 2001 when it
experienced that shift to the northwest
in California it was the lowest year was
the seventh lowest in 2001 and in the
Rio Grande it was the fifth lowest in
2003 again showing in general that there
was a coherence about some condition of
drought that was exceptional and
record-breaking when we think about this
in a century-long context so water
resources are one of the things we were
thinking about but crop yield is another
one we were curious what was the impact
on crop yield especially knowing how
important that is for lively hoods in
the region showing our characteristic
blues and reds over the 97 207 period we
see the crop production over the region
showed a large decline particularly in
the year 2000 to now recall in your mind
if you can the distribution of
agricultural production in the region
it's largely concentrated in California
and so there was significant drought in
the in the Central Valley part in this
year two thousand two which is why that
was the large negative reduction
our large negative anomaly about
thirteen percent compared to the average
we also see this in terms of the the PDF
or the frequency distribution of
county-level normalized productivity so
this is crop yield at a county level for
2383 counties I think it was and you see
the distribution during the drought
shifted to the left relative to the non
drought conditions not every County
experienced a significant drought in all
of these years some of them had banner
years but most of them did not and
here's a spatial look at that context
this is now crop productivity expressed
its net primary productivity it's the
relative difference compared to the non
drought mean drought minus non drought
and I'll just point out the orange in
red there's off there's an awful lot of
yellow and even some green green is
above average but there's quite a lot of
red and orange particularly in this this
domain just indicating that there were
as much as thirty percent mean
reductions in crop yield for some places
another source of information that
allows us to quantify the impact of this
drought is this network that I work with
quite a lot Eddie flux Network professor
Lee here works also with any flux quite
a bit so you might already be familiar
with these towers but here's a picture
from one of the sites at which I've
worked that's actually skukuza South
Africa in the kruger park but it's
indicate evoke eynde of sensors that we
have this is about 35 meters off the
ground a sonic anemometer pointing out
to the upwind direction and measuring at
20 Hertz or 10 Hertz the three
dimensions of three directions of
velocity it also measures carbon dioxide
and water concentration and temperature
with a whole set of fast response
sensors the covariance the mean
covariance over an averaging period
allows us to measure the mass exchange
between surface and atmosphere of water
carbon dioxide heat sensible heat as
well as momentum and so there is a
network of these globally it's sparse
it's biased in its representation across
the globe but one place where we do
happen to have
you can say a ring of network a ring of
sensors that can be used as a network is
throughout the western United States and
so each red dot is one tower each blue
dot is a numbered number of towers to
two or three and what we did was
something kind of unusual which is to
say we we know not every place
experience drought in every year but
let's say let's look at whether or not
this network of flux towers had a
detected a measurable effect of this
coherent drought this large-scale
drought pulling them as an observatory
and I think you'll see that we we found
this to be a pretty successful technique
this network is composed of data
contributed by a heterogeneous number of
investigators each with site level
funding the Department of Energy is
supported this through the Americs
funding that they provide but the site
pis deserve a lot of credit for
contributing these data for synthesis of
this sort here's the kind of thing that
we saw we're going to first look at the
baseline condition this is the average
non drought condition busy graphic the
first three terms NEP gpp and ecosystem
respiration our carbon flux terms that
is ecosystem carbon fluxes the next to
our energy balance terms energy flux
terms i should say Leighton energy flux
and sensible heat flux which will be
familiar for many we're showing this
four classes of vegetation types that
were detected or measured by these these
flux towers the flux towers have a
kilometer scale footprint that shifts
with wind direction and so it's a fairly
local measure and it tend these tend to
be located in a place where we know the
vegetation cover its characteristics and
so forth we have eight towers that
measure the exchanges for evergreen
Eataly forests for towers and grasslands
and three towers and woody savannas and
what we're showing here is the
aggregation of those over the
observational network again for the
baseline period so starting on the
bottom left we have net ecosystem
productivity this is shown in grams of
carbon per square meter per year and we
see a reassuring pattern well let me let
me start by saying net ecosystem
productivity is closest to the measured
carbon flux but we can separate that
into primary productivity and ecosystem
respiration
Shin with a technique I'd be happy to
tell you about later but what it does is
it shows us some first of all reassuring
patterns evergreen needle e-force tend
to be in the wetter places that also
have higher productivity and so indeed
we see that productivity in these
evergreen needle II force exceeds that
of the dryer grasslands as well as the
savannas the woody savannah types
another reassuring pattern of a sort is
that when it comes to evaporation we see
that grasslands this orange bar tend to
be pretty water use intensive that's a
classic characteristic habit of grasses
and their water use strategy use it or
lose it it's a little bit more like the
grass habit and it turns out that indeed
they do generally use more water through
avapro transpiration than the typical
use for a forest or a woody savannah the
woodier types so there's a lot of detail
in these slides and I'm not going to
have chance to go through everything but
what I'm now going to do is say well how
is the drought the five-year drought
period different from this baseline
condition so this is the anomaly and
it's calculated as the direct the fluxes
during the drought minus the baseline
average so these are the anomalies same
terms same color bars and now what we
see is a few prevailing patterns first
of all in two of the three ecosystem
types we see significant reductions in
productivity in net ecosystem
productivity we see both gross primary
productivity that's primary production
and co2 sequestration through
photosynthesis we see that increase are
decreasing we also see a decrease in
ecosystem respiration but the decrease
in plant productivity exceeds the
decrease in respiration and so there
there ends up being a net lost uptake of
carbon that's what this negative sign of
any P means that is if you think it's
good that ecosystems mitigate greenhouse
gas pollution through pulling co2 down
that was reduced that effect was reduced
particularly in forests and grasslands
we didn't see that effect in woody
savannas that's an interesting outcome
you can think about why that might be
the case but my story is that microbes
don't have deep roots but plants do okay
woody savannas have deep roots microbes
are the source of a lot of the
decomposition and the release of co2 to
the atmosphere the microbes and the the
carbon that they consume tends to be
concentrated in the upper soils that
dries out during these droughts and so
respiration this is well reported
respiration declines and plummets
especially in dry places meanwhile woody
savannas have deep roots they access a
much larger volume soil water and they
have reserves and strategies that allow
them to carry over productivity to some
degree during droughts so the absence of
deep roots for microbes is one of the
explanations for why woody savannas had
actually a increased uptake yes
five percent
there's not a lot of support in this
model great question you could see
because of the water use intensiva T of
C 3 versus C for some interesting
patterns that would emerge but there's
not a lot of c-4 here when it comes to
evaporation we saw also decreases that's
this lef term in watts per meter squared
radiative term or an energy term we see
decreases across the board the the
baseline was something like 28 or so I
the percentages are here excuse me
twenty-five percent reduction in
evaporation in Evergreen eataly for us
more modest and grasslands again their
water use intensive and then a sixteen
percent reduction in the woody savannas
we also saw not shown here an increase
in air temperatures that's measured at
these flux towers as well and there was
generally a point for degree celsius
increase on average during the summer
season i should have said for this
particular set of sites and then lastly
we see an interesting pattern in
sensible heat flux in grasslands it
decreased there was less sensible heat
flux it increased in the other two what
would you expect if what if evaporation
is going down you would expect sensible
heats got to go up right the energy goes
somewhere and that's what you would
generally see except in grasslands
they're neat they're different they're
different because they siness and they
become white and their albedo increases
dramatically they also show more soil so
the total net radiation energy available
and input into the system can decrease
that's a pretty well known and well
reported kind of phenomenon so it's
interesting it's neat that the the
network also detected that kind of
effect so this is simply to say that we
also see a large reduction in primary
productivity and net carbon uptake that
would otherwise offset the carbon
emissions associated with say other land
with fossil fuel dependence there's
another thing we can do with this we can
try to scale up to the aggregate area
averaged total carbon uptake in the
baseline condition in these ecosystems
and then how it was reduced during the
drought
that's what we're showing here this is
for gross primary productivity for two
terms but I'm going to jump down to the
net ecosystem productivity and there are
two ways in which we can look at this
one is with atmospheric inversions
transport tracer inversions and co2
flask network and then by using the flux
tower data themselves I want to focus
first on the baseline sink and we're
seeing that in general the inversions
suggest the atmospheric inversion
suggests that about a hundred to two
hundred let's say 150 to 200 tera grams
of carbon per year are taken up in the
average condition in the western United
States by ecosystems there are other
things that might contribute but it
really looks like the missing sink in
this region is is sizable and it's of
that magnitude the question is how was
it reduced how big which was the
reduction in during the drought period
turns out it was about 3283 depending on
source this is I remember that the top
line is for carbon tracker if you know
these the bottom line is for a Christian
road and becks llena inversion from the
mox plant biogeochemistry Institute
there but I think what's most reliable
and important is the percentage
differences we see that 17 to forty four
percent depending on data source with
these inversions 17 to forty four
percent reductions in this carbon uptake
which is the baseline condition that's a
significant number that's a sizable
number now we can get a similar number
forty-eight percent using the flux tower
network but the raw data the absolute
values are quite different why is that
which one should we trust well the
jury's out but we suspect as fluxed our
users that there are large sources
releases of carbon dioxide that are not
well detected by the flux tower network
and so these numbers that this seems
implausible to me working the global
carbon 623 tera grams of carbon half a
pedigree of carbon if you work in the
carbon say that's a large number fawcett
global deforestation is about annually
about 1 to 2 pedda grams of carbon per
year global land change emissions so
this is about half of that to a third of
that that's a large number and just for
the u.s. west that's implausible but
what I think that network does do
is provide a good relative measure say a
forty-eight percent reduction I think we
had a more confidence in that number so
I want you to be careful and I'm careful
in the way I use these numbers but I
think that's more reliable but that's
not the whole story there was also a
large uptick in fire emissions
associated with this drought event here
we have from the landsat derived
monitoring trends and burn severity
mapping of the area of forests based on
the USGS data on 1984 to 2008 record of
burned area and this is shown by
category and year category is low medium
high severity fires and what you can
clearly see is that the average over
that full record is this black line and
during the turn of the century drought
the height of bars is high relative to
that average and perhaps an even better
reference would be the average during
this pre turn the century drought you
can see that fire missions were far
larger well this is now area so but this
translates pretty directly into firing
missions here it is in terms of fire
emissions the size of the blue bar
increased because high severity fires
emit more than low severity fires so
there's a disproportionate impact on
carbon release and this is from some of
the work of bar down community a PhD
student of mine has just recently
published this in JGR bio geosciences we
found we calculated a roughly 25
telegram of carbon additional release
per year due to an uptick in fires was
this due only to the drought or do you
maybe see a general trend of an increase
in fire area and any missions there is
and it's not just during the drought in
fact these were not especially dry years
across the region but fire emissions
were also large then and we generally
see a sizable increase in fire emissions
across this region that's taking place
today so that's part of the story as
well and then just to wrap up this
vignette of the full impact of this
particular drought what's been happening
recently is also relevant part of what
gained gave a lot of attention
the work that we've recently published
was the fact that when it was released
it was published in July of 2012 the
country was undergoing a significant and
severe drought very much like in its in
extent the Dust Bowl now it extended
well into the interior in ways that the
turn of the century drought didn't
necessarily but if you look at the West
the western US experienced again another
whammy of a year in terms of low runoff
water shortages and associated impacts
and so one could ask well with all of
these droughts going on and these
sizable impacts that are meaningful in a
lot of ways how does this fit into the
broader long-term context is this
unusual for the area or is it common
place and so that's where we're going to
transition to the third element of the
talk which is about a thousand year
history and if you're worried about time
these get progressively shorter so the
thousand-year history is is a context
from a long tree-ring chronology
developed by ed cook not our work but
again its backdrop in context for the
sorts of things we're studying and it
tells a simple story that it used to be
drier than today or at least a recent
yesterday this is a busy way of showing
the texture of the data from the
tree-ring chronology but this is the way
we presented it again based on ed cooks
work from the lamont-doherty observatory
this arrow indicates the five-year
average Palmer drought severity
reconstruction from that tree ring
chronology and some tree rings do indeed
go back as far as 1200 years into the
past now we get progressively fewer
trees and corresponding as we go back in
time and we should we should have
progressively increased concern or
skepticism or caution in the way we use
the data as we go back in time but
what's clear is it when we would let's
say we I believe that this is the best
record we can get but if we were to go
back to about 1600 when we have greater
confidence in the record you can see
that there was one five-year average
drought or PDFs I condition that was
similar in magnitude to that in
thousand and in fact there were only
four events in this 1200 year historical
context that were as large or larger
when did those occur it happened long
into the past 802 about 1100 and 1200 to
1300 we were talking a little bit about
this with Carl well back into the past
Medieval Warm Period sorts of times if
if we're correct the stein one in Stein
to this is a long time in the past we
don't really know what caused that it
wasn't greenhouse gas forcing but
clearly there was a dry period in the
distant past and I think that ed cooks
graphic provides an even better
illustration at the same time series the
raw texture of the data is overlain by
some kind of spline I don't know the
timescale of that but it clearly
indicates now in this case let me
explain this is percent drought area in
percent drought area across this domain
of the West very similar domain and so
positive means dryer- or lower on the
graph reductions is wetter and you can
see that during this period of what they
called mega droughts the West Was was a
lot drier and most more recently we've
had a good fortune of a relatively wet
period and in fact in as I was
suggesting before in the early 1900's it
was a very wet West compared to this
long record just so happens that that's
when we were exploring and setting up
all sorts of contracts for water usages
and today's reality over allocates the
water on an annual basis because a lot
of those contracts were drawn up in a
relatively pluvial period another thing
that we can see with the recent record
is a strong return towards dry
conditions very much like those of the
mega droughts long ago and so in general
in this part of the country it's been
getting drier and drier throughout the
20th century so that's the Thousand Year
historical context and now we want to
turn to the Future to see if if it
happened in the past with what's likely
to come if we don't change our fossil
fuel dependence what might what might
there be to pass and
this is this title that Trudy mentioned
was 100-year forecast drought we didn't
choose that title the New York Times did
of course but I think it's still true to
the message and I changed it to drier
than we'd like this comes now from the
cmap five multi-model ensemble average
precipitation again selected for this
particular domain the same domain we've
been looking at and it spans 1902 2100
the turn of the century drought is right
in the middle and you can see that
indeed the models suggest just like the
data than in general there's a trend
towards less wet conditions and under a
high emission scenario that's expected
to get worse and worse and worse over
the next hundred years so right this was
with the representative concentration
pass pathway 8 or 8 watts per meter
squared and this is from me little so
we'd simply use that recent data source
and detected or observed that there are
a few important points here first of all
the turn of the century drought was
exceptional relative to the 20th century
it was a major drought unparalleled
according to the models and also
relative to the observational records
and what is it likely to how does it
stand in the future climate ology it
stands out as a wet anomaly in fact a
wet anomaly that doesn't happen
according to the models by the mid to
late 21st century so is a major drought
that stands out similar to the mega
droughts of a thousand years ago and
with greenhouse forcing it's suggested
according to the models that we will not
see a wet condition as wet as the turn
of the century drought
tomorrow all models model for the dates
this is mom mark what are the dates well
example the dates are when you're in the
future either a model is very wise
greenhouse task force more than other
other things that makes that particular
games yeah so I don't just for the for
the audio and video the question is well
was this all model based or and where do
we transition as well as what were the
dates of some of the the drivers of the
patterns that we would see in the models
including greenhouse gas forcings and
other things well prior to I don't know
what the exact boundary is but let's say
it's maybe 2010 we have an observed
history of fossil fuel emissions and
some other observational constraints
that were used to to help drive the
models okay so that's one piece going
forward of course there's an emission
scenario which is now actually a
concentration in the atmosphere and that
that's that that's this RCP 8 watts per
meter squared in the seam of five we
have a different approach it's not or
the modelers have a different approach
it's not a one BA 2 and B 1 any longer
it's a concentration pathway
concentration in the atmosphere and
that's what would run forward from about
20 10 is there another question there
maybe I didn't catch
right so there's a comment about how
aerosol variation in the future is also
a part of what these models would would
be projecting and forecasting it's not
just greenhouse gases right now I see
what you're getting at the point is
that's right so I think the point is
that while there's greenhouse gas and
other aerosol type forcings atmospheric
composition forcings what it the
question is partly what gives rise to
the year-to-year variation and the
swings and the anomalies that we see in
this record its internal variability
within the model system the climate
system is it smack on for any given year
no I don't think so is the range of
variability consistent with that which
has been observed over the 20th century
yes it is we tested that we evaluated a
quantile quantile plot of precipitation
anomalies over the West and we saw that
the model is fidelis to the data that is
that it reproduces the range of
variability and the statistical extremes
of precipitation for the 20th century
suggesting that it's capable of
capturing year-to-year variations and
natural variability that's not forced by
punctuated emissions it's a smooth
emissions content and atmospheric
concentration profile what we didn't
have in our work because the data
weren't yet fully available but but I'd
like to point out is the spread across
models this is now back to a paper by
Richard Seager also at lamont-doherty
with the cmap 3 archive and the results
are anyway very similar to what we see
with seema 5 not that much has changed
in the models of the way they run and
the pink envelope is what I'm going to
point out first of all this is now
precipitation minus evaporation it's a
little bit different from just
precipitation but what we see is an
envelope the 25th is 75th percentile pop
high end and 25th percentile low and
across the models around a multi-model
mean which I'm sorry I don't it's the
red line okay
and it just indicates the range of
variability across models which I think
also underscores the degree to which the
year per year specific precision is not
clear in the models nor would it be
expected to be but but the the range of
variability in the in the pink envelope
is really the spread between models and
the way their internal variability
evolves their sensitivity to initial
conditions and so forth also different
model physics model structure all of
that feeds in to the spread that we see
here another thing that I must admit I
don't fully understand is that the range
of variability across models gets
increasingly large part of that is just
that the model physics the model
structure is different the strength of
feedbacks with the same emissions
forcing the same concentrations in the
atmosphere that changes and there's the
classic spread and amplification
associated with how models differ but in
general notice that they all show a
trend towards reduced precipitation
minus evaporation or reduce
precipitation if you will throughout the
Western domain and here's the same data
source presented spatially and by season
this is now precipitation or percent
change less precipitation in brown more
and blue shown in winter spring summer
and fall from top left to lower right
this is from Michael wehner and in the
usg CRP the global change research
programs report in 2009 and I the
hatching indicates places where there's
a multi-model confidence regarding the
magnitude or agreement about the sign
and magnitude of these changes we can
see that some parts of North America get
wetter in winter but certainly some
parts are expected to get drier the
exact boundary is not well described we
don't know where that boundary should be
in spring and summer though we see a
general coherence and confidence cross
models particularly here in the
northwest and here in the southwest that
there will be precipitation reductions
we could expect that with a high
emission scenario going forward this is
again based on CMM three but it's
showing us a story that's consistent
with the
CERN's that we observed regarding the
context of the turn of the century
drought what it looks like in the past
and what it could be in the future so
that's what led us to think about taking
the New York Times up on their
invitation to write an opinion piece
which felt like a very daunting and
frightening thing to do and Christopher
schwam myself and kevin schafer co-wrote
this during our vacations over the
summer it just felt too important it
felt like we had to sound an alarm that
has been sounded before but that is a
clear future that I think we could all
agree we wouldn't want if we could avoid
it without too many costs that's a big
if and in the process of writing this we
came across in our interactions with the
general public and even some scientists
what I classified is four major
arguments that challenge the conclusions
or should we care can we believe in it
and I just wanted to share those with
you I don't have answers to every single
one but I think some of them are are
actually easy to defend and maybe even
the wrong questions or challenges the
first is that the thousand-year history
was drier dry is a normal condition in
the West and that the 20th century has
actually been pretty wet so why are we
so worried about drought why are we
worried about this future I think
clearly we can see that a return to the
dry condition of a thousand years ago in
the next hundred years would bring a
radically altered a dramatically
different can average condition in the
West that probably wouldn't be habitable
and used used in the same way so I don't
know if that's a reasonable challenge
but interesting observation indeed the
second is that natural variability is
large and past routes were even caused
without human forcing so the
year-to-year variations and probably
even the turn of the century drought
which gets on to the next point we
couldn't attribute them directly to
greenhouse gas forcing and most of them
are driven by natural variability
connections to El Nino and La Nina type
conditions here la ninia or the PDO the
amo all sorts of teleconnections in the
atmosphere it isn't that what's driving
droughts so perhaps we shouldn't be as
concerned so that's another challenge
and
get to that with a sort of a parian in
the next slide and then lastly climate
models are forecasts they're flawed
models they have biases they have spread
and so how could we why should we alter
our behavior today given all of these
uncertainties their error prone in
uncertain and it's especially so when it
comes to drought predictions so I agree
that that's a concern but when all the
models are pointing in a similar
direction about a change in the climate
not just in the American Southwest but
globally I think maybe there's still
reason to to be concerned and here's
part of my in a sense explanation for
why I agree this is hard to assimilate
and understand I myself have have
trouble getting my head around it but
here's one here's a working hypothesis
as I come to think about climate change
more and more back to the same record
you can see that natural variability is
large and real and that there were
droughts of the past but what's
happening with greenhouse gases as we
all know here is that they're
accumulating into the atmosphere and
that makes it really hard when you're
sitting right here to understand what
the impacts will be like in the future
to take the past 60 years of significant
fossil fuel emissions in greenhouse
gases accumulating the atmosphere see
modest scientifically defendable but
somewhat modest resource impacts and
then think about the wall that's coming
which is an accumulated compounding
effect of the next 60 years of emissions
it's very hard for us to think about an
exponential landscape it's hard enough
linearly but when the wall that's coming
is very steep as it is in this case when
it's accumulated and in fact
accumulating not even linearly but it's
growing in a curvilinear shape and
sticking around for a long time say a
hundred year average lifetime for a co2
molecule assuming that sinks behave the
same in the future this has a long
lasting effect and a compounding effect
because of accumulation in the
atmosphere and that makes it very hard
to think about even a significant
drought today that cannot be on
ambiguously attributed to greenhouse
gases nor have we tried to but to place
that in a context as a representation of
what's likely to come with a continued
path of fossil fuel dependence in our
way of life that's a hard problem to
wrap your head around I admit that but
it seems clear that not only are we
talking about a drier future but we're
not even talking about droughts anymore
the natural variability remains but look
at the progression of the future natural
variability is still large in fact maybe
it gets larger maybe that's partly
because of the multi-model ensemble but
even when you have that natural
variability which is the what we usually
think about is drought we're talking
about a transition and what's climate
normal we're not really talking about
droughts anymore so if we think that it
was bad in the turn of the century
drought and unparalleled we need to
think differently about whether that's
even a reasonable analogue for what it
could be like in the future throughout
this region and so I'll return to this
slide which is that yes the West the
u.s. West is dry by nature but it could
become without a change in our fossil
fuel dependence and even drier future
because of humans and it's an
intensification of the Hadley cell and
expansion of the subtropical high a
shift towards the poles and a stronger
dryer kind of condition that prevails
over the western US and then very
quickly global outlook is this only in
the western US or is it a global
challenge looks like it's a global
challenge the models are as we've all
heard suggesting that dry places
globally could become drier the hatching
is again places with multi-model
confidence nine out of 11 of the cement
five models that were used by egg will
die in a recent nature climate change
paper and it sure we see a strong
pattern in the western US domain that
we're thinking about but there are many
other parts of the planet where
precipitation shortages soil moisture
shortages and the attendant and
commensurate impacts on water resources
used for by humans agricultural
production and so forth could be
challenged on
something was to change so with that my
conclusions are just that this turn of
the century drought was significant it
was a five-year anomaly and one of the
largest in the past millennium it caused
a large reduction in water availability
and we see this in multiple lines of
evidence it reduced the region's
productivity in a substantial way and
this offset some of the typical carbon
uptake for that region which in fact
would be I didn't talk about it but a
feedback a positive feedback to the
amplification of warming if this was
greenhouse driven and forecast suggests
that this could be the wet end of a
future 21st century climate if we stay
on a high emissions future scenario so
with that I just want to return to some
acknowledgments again the National
Science Foundation and NASA and the
Department of Energy and thank the hosts
for having me here to deliver the
seminar thanks
please son consensus cement people about
why reserve any brighter I don't know if
it's unified and I don't think I would
represent that view well not being a
climate model ER or even a climatologist
my simple-minded understanding is it's
essentially an intensification behind
lee sell circulation and expansion of
that domain and basically you add energy
to the system and it intensifies this
circulation cell and intensifies the
subtropical high zone now i I don't
understand it for them that we were
talking about this with Carl and Trudy
before and in fact is it John you and I
started to touch on that topic a little
bit so I'd love to learn from this
Community about whether or not there's
consensus about the mechanism driving
that they're associated
there's changes in carbon uptake by
vegetation changes in albedo changes in
forest fires and so you know when you
combine the climate effect about all
that it's not here to me of the net
effect would be and I'm not sure how to
watch them those effects are all
included in climate models don't know if
you know I got the clinicals have
improved in terms of carbon cycle and so
I was wondering to what extent that's
part of the future scenario yeah well
there are a lot of positive and perhaps
even negative feedback effects that are
missing from the climate models one of
the the most significant that I think
about is the permafrost carbon feedback
now that may not show up for a hundred
years anyway as my colleague Kevin
schaeffer's worked on quite quite a lot
to suggest but it is going to be large
as a store stored future consequence so
that the models aren't perfect they
don't have everything in them when it
comes to some of the major drivers I
think they're actually not bad now again
I want to point out that the pink
shading got larger over time across
models that's because each model is has
its own internal dynamics they end up
creating a widening envelope of the
future projections so that's fodder for
and fuel for additional research some
some of which I'd like to contribute to
in my work on the land carbon cycle a
lot of it lies in just what happens to
say the Amazon and drought stricken
forest Sun and models do very different
things with respect to the water cycle
and its impacts on the carbon cycle the
albedo effect we could certainly improve
but I think that those models are have
have the best data in the best date have
been brought to bear on how we treat
surface albedo with a changing climate
in terms of hydrology and and water
status its influence on albedo surface
albedo and in fact interestingly land
cover change generates co2 emissions and
a greenhouse gas forcing but also in
general the past land cover changes and
many of the future cause a more
reflective surface and so these things
act in opposite directions so
looking backwards land cover change has
we believe had a net cooling effect
because the albedo forcing outweighs the
greenhouse gas forcing going in
different directions so that are all in
the models insofar as we understand them
today one of the problems is of course
we have understanding in specific places
but we don't know about it everywhere so
there's work to be done but a lot of the
major mechanisms are I think in there
one last thing is again not my area of
expertise but I understand that that
clouds are a major unknown and how
clouds will evolve and change in the
future their direct radiative effects
based on whether they're low or high in
the atmosphere that's a big unknown and
that's another major source of
uncertainty in the way this climate
models would make projections so I don't
know if I know not everything is in
there and I know they're spread in part
due to all of these uncertain mechanisms
but just one last thing is that they
they clearly show that accumulation of
greenhouse gases in the atmosphere will
drive these regions to a drier future
and there's agreement about that
you